Yeah in our series three meals you know
what we do we sample some local
favorites while also sampling the minds
of Voters ahead of the midterms and this
morning the land of sun the land of surf
and the land of my one and only
childhood do we have the picture please
tell me we do
there it is come on we're talking
Florida of course that's a parrot on My
Head by the way long live the Parrot
Jungle Florida once the nation's Premier
swing state I think that's fair to say
also fair to say the state is now
trending Republican it had gone back and
forth in presidential elections since
Bill Clinton was President but former
president Trump expanded his lead here
from 2016 to 2020 and registered
Republicans this is historic now
outnumber registered Democrats so what
we do well we swung up from Miami to
Jacksonville to find out why Florida May
no longer swing for Democrats
Miami Miami
is where we found Enriquez a Cuban
sandwich and Coffee Spot still making it
in Midtown you know every morning not to
stop here every single more Justin
Kaplan starts the day with un Cafe Sito
and two of these croquetas can I have
what he's having I don't have that one
yeah we'll change your life and for our
sake he added a side of local
perspective on Republican Governor Ron
DeSantis I didn't go phone the first
time I won't vote for him again I still
think it's been unfairly vilified and I
think that the national narrative and
certainly the narrating outside of the
State of Florida is again it's
absolutely not in line with what's
really going on down as we moved inside
over a plate of bacon and eggs we
learned something else that Florida
Outsiders may forget there's a
difference between Cuban voters and
Latino voters Cubans tend to to vote
Republican diami Marquez is one of a
million Q even Americans around Miami
and when it comes to Ron DeSantis he's a
beast why is he a beast I like the way
he does everything and that includes his
decision to send migrants from the south
to States up North I'm an immigrant
but I came illegal I believe in legal
immigration I don't believe in illegal
immigration we chased that thought with
a little fresh-squeezed Florida OJ all
right is really good I love that
and walked out with a bag of enriqueta's
Famous Steak Sandwiches really good
before heading for the highway
driving north along I-95 we hit Central
Florida home of the Space Coast and tens
of thousands of new residents many of
whom seem to lean Republican as they
register to vote our next stop Pub
Americana in the heart of downtown
Melbourne where Dave Hildebrand was kind
enough to offer a taste of his fried
Gator bites
there's Philly
but what really gave us something to
chew over came from Dave Hoban we have
our freedoms here yeah you know a lot
more than the other states he says the
economy is a top concern but a bigger
motivator for him is the culture but
what's going to pushing is the
distribution of the ideas all these
other
things and ideas that quite frankly are
coming up or being forced down on a lot
of people's throats so we're going to
stand up and
they're going to get voted down after
tucking into a burger and a craft beer
we heard from two women across the room
who sounded like they might lean
Democrat especially on the issue of
abortion women shouldn't have a choice
to do what they want it's not my
decision to tell someone else what to do
but Catherine Graham and Tommy fryer
both registered Independence
like what Ron DeSantis is cooking up on
just about every other issue he's just
like on it especially with how he
handled covid like yeah I feel like that
was a big contributing factor to it I
just feel like he's very family oriented
he you know cares about the people
doesn't like you know
doesn't BS around with two meals down we
were soon back on the road
[Music]
final stop Jacksonville a big political
surprise in 2020 when the county flipped
blue for the first time in more than
four decades it's where we found tree
Mendes barbecue and met with owner Terry
Roundtree don't worry thanks for having
us thank you who recently had to make
some adjustments increasing cost of
operation what's going on there can I
say Baden you can say whatever's on your
mind it wasn't like that when Trump was
President for dinner I wanted something
a little lighter so I'm kind of hoping
you got a salad do you really yeah hot
dog I'm gonna have a steak and a burger
on it
it also came with a side of nostalgia
from Terry's brother Ricky and customer
Daniel Quinn as they discussed
desantis's fight against the so-called
woke left before we didn't have to think
about what you said now you really got
to think about it before you say it it's
a free country we have it says we have
free speech why can't you say what you
want
pretty clear Democrats have their work
cut out for them here and not only in
2022 Terry Roundtree likes Ron DeSantis
for governor and Beyond do you like them
for 2024
and the White House yeah absolutely
really absolutely over that other
Florida resident absolutely really
absolutely
pretty big storyline developing there uh
by the way I got to point out that once
we started digesting our food and
digesting the day we realized that on
that day-long trip we spoke to dozens of
people up and down the coast of Florida
all in precincts by the way that voted
for President Biden in 2020 but to our
surprise we did not run into a supporter
of Ron desantis's Democratic opponent
that would be Charlie Crist but we did
find some Chris supporters last weekend
as we stopped by a get out the vote
rally he held take a look at what they
had to say
what is the number one thing that makes
you support Charlie democracy democracy
in every aspect how do you think Charlie
Chris campaign for governor is going
I think it could have gone stronger
because the Democrats do not took their
own Owens what is the number one issue
that leads you to support Charlie Crist
for governor women's rights women's
rights so you think Ron DeSantis is
going to go further to restrict abortion
you already robbing us of our freedom
and that's and freedom is not free until
you're free to make your own decision he
says he's the freedom guy he's not
Freedom he has stole our freedom from
the state of Florida yes
so there we go we promised conversations
on both sides of the issues both parties
uh and there you have it Tony it was
interesting though about the Ron
DeSantis voters that you go from one end
of the state to the other and I know you
were looking you only found found
Charlie Chris supporters at a Charlie
Chris rally it was really that difficult
yeah it was really that tough at one
point I stood at a stop sign and flagged
down every single car to ask the driver
who they were supporting for governor at
another point I went to a diner that
wasn't even on our list this was meal
four of the day went to every table and
couldn't find one that's anecdotal
that's not scientific uh Charlie Chris
supported are out there but it does
speak to the fact that Ron DeSantis in
the last four years after just barely
winning the governorship in 2018 has
done a really strong job of
consolidating support thank you Tony